我叫你
你好
我叫Eon
你的指导在这个世界
但你可问你
这是
Sky
你
Hey, good man.
沒力的
滴墟 地上都靠上了
彼此回路
那我和我亚得在家理
我天啊
我猜人一百期
那些都哪不
我看早别は
我看早就一屈
因为我这不够
那么专门
才都把我
吃甜了
我看了
然后都看不见
我看什么
那你说什么
MING PAO我用了这些我的面子我抬着他 他在巴一舟我吹有用头子我再嘢戴好专门我也打了,我唐帅我
我喜欢小君子
说你猟子
就在那里面
让他搞了
在这些里面
让我知道
我给你
我们冻说
看到他
要不要
我
Degra Seu dale tu en la cabeza
Vemóstate quieto que lo asegure
Samos tres diemos en un carro sin placa
Miramos a uno y tiramos los que
Vamos no tan loco porque hasta me vende
Pero nunca prueba yo le dejaré
Y a lo contrario no se dejan ver
Y yo con la toda nueva que compré
Por los bloques en paz sola no pasa
Porque tienen miedo de irse a pie
Con Memo le hice un atentado
Que ni siquiera nos pudieron ver
Pas que gata fuerte en pitola
Si no tienen grano pa resolver
Un tiro a la cabeza y como Maluma el morro que hace
La fe es lo último que se pierde
如果不是在最訪的信心
我們開始了被人造成了
然後我們上了誰雛
我們是刺生物的
有很多人在一起
Cuchy no love, B
Riva
拜拜